what's going on guys Deadpool it's
pretty much made the box-office it's
[ __ ] but not the first r-rated comic
book movie today we are going to
establish the definitive list the top
nine r-rated comic book movies of all
time why are we doing nine random choice
here we go and we've got a pretty cool
panel talk about it with first he is the
director of development at Collider
video and you know I'm from schmoes know
and Fandango Kristian harloff movie
fights champion your friend of mine damn
ro fellas first off the success of
Deadpool are you surprised by it what
are your thoughts yeah if I'm being
completely honest the trailers didn't do
a lot for me and when I saw the movie
obviously I'm like this far exceeded my
expectation what it shows is that when
you have someone as passionate about Tim
Miller and Ryan Reynolds who are
embracing this and worked so hard on
doing it with the you can't just make
r-rated comic book movies no to make
them you have to be passionate about
them you have to know what you're making
and that's the reason it is the success
that it is
we compiled our top 9 list of r-rated
movies but first there are several films
that did not make our final list shall
we check out the honorable mentions
sure roll the honorable mentions this
matter time I suppose
don't but who do you think you're
fooling I just saw you I'm glad at you
victims aren't we all it's about five or
six I have sexually attracted to Bugs
Bunny what are we in slow motion here
now what do you hypnotize that's the
more kids why don't you so what you're
saying is you identify with those nerds
yes I consider myself a nerd
the big one that people are gonna I
think the surprise is not on our list is
Watchmen right and there are a lot of
fans of that movie I think we all agree
that Watchmen is a great fantastic
graphic novel the movie maybe didn't
resonate as much as the source yeah I
felt kind of the same way I think that
if you as far as how it looks it looks
like it came right off the the graphic
novel straight into yeah the film I was
the only one that had Watchmen on my
list that opening sequence is one of the
best things ever put to film comic book
wise it is certainly a film to be
admired yeah it is absolutely a thumb to
be admired our final list should we
start with number nine and work our way
down let's do it all right V for
Vendetta
theory verdict is vengeance a vendetta
depending on who you ask it's our it's
the sneaky lost wachowski film which
housekeys had a lot to do with the
directing this film J's McTeague kind of
directed it now yeah in name but I but I
will say that this movie to me I love
this film I liked it the more and more I
watch that Hugo Weaving was also the the
lead character here too who also he
replaced James Purefoy
I don't know if a lot of people knew
that as well - yeah that happened for I
think first half of the movie but there
was just so much in that from the far as
the the chemistry I thought between a
guy in a mask and Natalie Portman but
better chemistry with a guy in a mask
than she did of all the prequels yeah
yeah and and I I didn't know anything
about the comic at all the vendetta
going and I've read it sense number once
a fantastic adaptation material but it's
also very cinematic the the I'm a big
fan of the use of music and stuff and
that yeah the setting to the attack on
Parliament with the 1812 overture that's
just so cinematic and such a great way
to take a striking image from the comic
and translate it cinematically yeah epic
climax really well done that's number 9
on our list number 8 this movie is just
a visual schwöre gas board 300
yes this was really I think Zack
Snyder's coming-out party even though he
had he had the dead remade but it but
this was the one that was this guy the
drop Butler again also showing up jokes
about the ABS and everything get sure
but work out it blew me away when I saw
in the theater yeah I was another one
that I wasn't really prepared for cuz it
was if I recall it was kind of dumped
into what is traditionally the early
morn up in ground March and I remember
seeing his like that so blew my
expectations as far as like I did not
expect anything like that I'd never seen
anything quite like that ten years ago
people were talking about 300 like
they're talking about Deadpool very true
yeah absolutely
number 7 on our list kick ass who are
you
I'm kick-ass I mean for me it's still
Aaron Johnson's best work and that
really was an arrival for Matthew Vaughn
yeah he had done Stardust and layer cake
but it absolutely was because this is a
movie but you got a little girl is
cursing like this and killing people
you're not gonna put that on screen and
he did it and he did it really well like
a Nicholas Cage Nicolas Cage is that
this might not have been on my personal
top nine but I can't begrudge it being
on this top nine because just for
Nicolas Cage alone but it's really no
more painful than a punch of the chest
hey you're gonna be fine baby doll
absolutely and McLovin is great in that
as well yeah great roles on the globe
that Christopher mintz-plasse uh last
wee unfairly typecast up as Macbeth yes
everybody which we have done so next we
went a little back and forth uh we
wanted a blade movie on there I
preferred blade to Christian up furred
blade Dan wait in well with blade some
mother always trying to ice-skate oval
yeah the only reason for me that I think
bleed just gets a little higher than
blade two is because it's set the way it
was without blade one obviously you
don't del Toro's not able to do what he
did in blade to pitch and Wesley Sam's
gonna walk around as a half vampire it
sounds ridiculous the movie still works
today and I still think it doesn't get
enough props for what it did because it
came out right before x-men did
superheroes kind of took a break they
did yeah laid was the one that really
came back first it's insane to think of
now but people forget that in the era of
daredevil and the Thomas Janke Punisher
for a long time blade was the good
Marvel movie yeah yeah yeah sure
absolutely
here's Matthew Vaughn again Kingsman oh
I love this mageddon
shoot the dog
I thought oh boy this looks like a
kick-ass ribeye he's just gonna do
kick-ass light what is this I'll go see
him blew me away did James Bond better
than James Bond has done it in 15 10 15
years yeah I liked how on the nose it
was for certain like throwback to the
old 60 spy movies and everything too but
even though Deadpool is doing big
numbers people are just glossing over
what Kingsman did last year
yeah have you made a lot of money and it
had no one in it didn't have a Ryan
Reynolds and Colin Firth was a great
actor but not a box-office draw and is
I'm gonna say has the the new young Han
Solo in the movie hoping dick Taylor
like Nostradamus but I think that that
kid you talk about a guy like who's
going to be around for a long time that
that watching that movie is like that
kid he's gone yeah yeah he goes from
street punk to dapper gentleman and and
back again that movie should not have
worked Nana did on all accounts
I was shocked how much I liked it number
four r-rated comic book movie of all
time
Sin City that's a comic book come to
life yeah you're making a big mistake
no big mistake yeah you already made a
big mistake yourself you didn't flush
also another one did not do great at the
box office and I actually think this is
one that didn't do great at the box
office
and I think it's been lost in the
shuffle a little bit over the years I
don't think people are talking about Sin
City as much as they used to yeah Mickey
Rourke and then doing a Marv I mean he
was so great everybody got Bruce Willis
you got Jessica Alba I've Owen o5o and a
lot of people to dismiss it or they
forget it well I think it's also because
the sequel to I think this you know
definitely yeah hurry along took a
little shine off the Apple there also I
think a little bloom comes off the Rose
when you have films eat that style and
don't deliver that style is not new
anymore and people see Sin City and
they're like oh that's just another
bling but that when it came out it was
not that oh yeah and it's a genre buster
too because it's not just a great comic
book movie it is one of the best modern
noir movies yes absolutely a film too
long yes and I think that's kind of the
reason that the movies not as successful
as maybe we hoped it was is because not
everybody responds to Nora
yeah I do you guys do a lot of film
lovers do but not everybody does it's
not a mainstream thing so I think that's
one of the reasons why it hasn't hit the
way we kind of hoped it would this next
one it's a salute to manga comics and a
really influential film when you think
about it
the original old boy didn't know until
we were doing our research that this was
based on manga what a great movie yeah
just a top of the brolin moon right yeah
it's not a cycling Spike Lee yeah yeah
no mind f yeah all the way around when
you see that I'm here just like wait a
minute there's certain things that I
didn't that's why I don't think that the
remake worked because if it is an
American version you can get away with
certain things coming from manga into
foreign film that works a lot better
than the transfer did in that movie when
you see it yeah don't if you haven't
seen it don't wiki it don't know it
don't fight the fighting I mean I
watched daredevil the even dared the
Netflix daredevil all the way fight
scene I was watching that I was like oh
boy yeah and it's it's it's funny though
too because that's a movie I guarantee
if you've never seen it before I don't
know anything about it you will at the
end of the movie Billy this old boy well
deserve recognition all right number two
Deadpool did I leave the stove on it
just struck that balance it really
earned that are and was so satisfying it
just was the movie that they promised it
would be it was a movie that the R
rating was a character in the movie it
was it was I mean the references to and
everything that they did with this movie
the marketing leading up to what the
movie would be they delivered and we
were talking about it it is a love story
it is a comedy it is a hardcore action
movie it's even a buddy comedy at times
um it's it just delivers on all
cylinders and it's not easy to do
breaking the fourth wall constantly but
from the opening credits it set this
tone and I was hooked I think you should
reward filmmakers who have such passion
and if you read about the development of
this Ryan Reynolds especially they just
were all in tune with one another and
you saw it on screen and the number one
film on our list the number one bar yeah
yeah um that's a different is oh uh the
number one r-rated comic book film of
all time Dredd this is Judge Dredd I
know all not Judge Dredd with Rob
Schneider and Sylvester Stallone
Dredd was just a tour de force
start-to-finish
action-packed it was and it was a great
example of an American movie taking
lessons from Asian cinema and and doing
it the right way which is not doing a
carbon copy of it but like let's take
this style let's make it our own and
let's find a formula that we that will
work with the style that we've decided
to go with
I saw that movie was blown away and it
was also you've got to give credit to
Karl Urban who is an actor he is a movie
star and he was totally cool
not showing his face the entire time
because that's not what the character
called for wasn't it was about this is
who he was all the way through it
thought Lena Headey was great I saw it
in the theater southern 3d was the best
use of 3d since avatar for sure wasn't
just converted it really worked and
served the story I'm bummed that it
never that we're not getting a sequel
for it's just not gonna happen
can I pitch something that might get it
a sequel please dread pool hmm how great
with that movie B I mean it sounds great
it seems like a no-brainer these are the
things they should not be made that many
are really so there you have it that's
our list
what's your list what do we leave off
let us know in the comments section
below
best answer and reasons why we will send
you a screen junkies t-shirt I got to
thank Kristian harloff check them out on
collider schmoes no Fandango and Dan
Merle check him out just hanging out
around the office also this Sunday the
most glamorous night in show business
the Oscars we're gonna have a crazy
super fun and stupid watch party an
Oscar watch parties can live streaming
please join us hang out with us tweet at
us we'll talk to you and make stupid
jokes about the Oscars join us then
Sunday night 5 p.m. Pacific Dan are you
gonna be there I will be there Christian
you're gonna be in a tuxedo at the
actual osco to be on the red carpet of
the Oscars yeah there you go
did I Claudia them uh they should you
handsome devil all right thanks for
watching on I'll run that hit me up on
Twitter bye bye
Ryan Cranston he's nominated for Trumbo
way back in 1982 he was a man struggling
with his very own sexuality do you want
to continue to live your the gay side of
your life you fulfilled needs that are
that I obviously can't